there is a sort of funny thing that you
hear people say that the time doesn't
actually exist and and it's something
that physicists argue about and
physicists actually have symposia on the
subject of is there such a thing as time
and it's also something that has a
tradition in philosophy going back about
a century but I think it's fair to say
that in one sense it's a ridiculous come
it's a ridiculous idea how can you say
time doesn't exist when we have such a
profound experience of it first of all
and second of all we're talking about it
constantly
I mean we couldn't we couldn't get I
can't get through this sentence without
referring to time I was going to say we
couldn't get through the day without
discussing time so obviously when a
physicist questions the existence of
time they are trying to say something
specialized something technical Einstein
offers Einstein or maybe I should say
more properly minkovski his teacher and
contemporary offers a vision of
space-time as a single thing as a
four-dimensional block in which the past
and the future are just like spatial
dimensions they're just like north and
south in the equations of physics and so
you can construct a view of the world in
which the future is already there and
you can say and physicists do say
something very much like this that in
the fundamental laws of physics there is
no distinction between the past and the
future and so if you're playing that
game you're essentially saying time as
an independent thing doesn't exist time
is just another dimension like space
again that is in obvious conflict with
our intuitions about the world we go
through the day
acting as though the past is over and
the future has not yet happened and
might happen this way or it might happen
that way we could flip a coin and see we
tend to believe in our gut that the
future is not fully determined and
therefore is different from the past but
physicists will say and it's certainly
true that a lot of things that we feel
in our gut turn out not to be right you
know we feel in our gut that we're
sitting on a flat plane on a surface of
something that's a mobile and if a
scientist came along and told you that
no you're actually on the surface of a
giant sphere that's spinning at high
speed and hurtling through space and by
the way there's no difference between up
and down except an illusion that's
created by the force of gravity well
you'd have to you'd have to do some
radical readjustment of your
understanding of the universe to accept
that your first intuitions weren't
correct and so if a physicist comes to
me and says do some readjustment face it
the future looks different from the past
to you but actually physics tells us
it's the same I at least acknowledge
that I have an obligation to take that
seriously to listen to it and and
physicists do argue about these things
and and it's fair to argue about it and
it's an argument that I take a position
on in my time-travel book because I felt
I had to or maybe I had a position and
and yet it's got to be a qualified
position and that's why that's what I
recommend to readers of science fiction
and to physicists to remember that your
views of these things are provisional